all right let's continue our coverage
who knew that a simple senate hearing
about covid
would lead to this much to discuss and
so many important issues that have to be
taken apart piece by piece by piece
we recently told you about when ted cruz
had to go
in front of his master i mean fox news
propagandist tucker carlson and grovel
and say i'm sorry tucker i was stupid i
said something wrong
i shouldn't have called the january 6
rioters terrorists
i'm sorry
i misspoke and he had to do a maya culpa
in front of the person who really has
the power in that relationship not the
us senator but the fox news propagandist
tucker carlson now tucker carlson loves
loves loves
the conspiracy theory that a man named
ray epps
was
supposedly a trumpist but actually an
undercover fed
inciting the riots because the fbi
organized the trump riots as a false
flag attack that that's sort of the gist
of it and you might remember that during
their interview right after ted cruz was
done groveling tucker started talking
about ray epps and ted cruz seeing it as
an opportunity to get back on the good
great in the good graces of tucker went
right along with it okay this is from
the other day and i agree
so who's ray epps by the way since you
are a senator like he and this other guy
are clearly encouraging the crowd
to commit crimes
neither one has been arrested or charged
what is that do you think so i think
that is a very good question i don't
know who ray epps is i've seen that
video multiple times it's disturbing
he's clearly urging the crowd to violate
the law when you see the crowd start
chanting fed fed fed for him to appear
on the fbi's most wanted list and come
off it certainly suggests he was working
for the fbi that's now that that is that
is riddled with lies let me let me play
a little more then i'll get back to that
conclusive but that's the obvious
implication and the attorney general and
the department of justice won't answer
the question doctor i can tell you i
joined with a number of other senators
trying to okay so you get the point
tucker loves this conspiracy theory now
it is just a conspiracy theory number
one
ray epps was never on the fbi's most
wanted he was he was never on the fbi's
most wanted there's a list that's the
fbi's most wanted and then there's other
things like when the fbi will release a
picture of people
that they want to talk to and after the
trump riots ray epps and i have the
picture up on the screen was on one of
these pictures in chronological order
from people they saw in the lower left
there's a picture of ray epps there this
is not the fbi's most wanted and not
every person on this list was charged it
wasn't only ray epps what do we know
about ray epps ray epps
um owns a wedding and event venue in
arizona
he's a retired u.s marine he's a trump
supporter he's connected to the
anti-government group the oath keepers
and he was listed as president of the
arizona chapter ray epps is on videos in
advance of the riots the day before
saying we've got to go to the capitol
and some people in the crowd go no fed
and ultimately it's it's what they did
on the day of the riots
he was there but he did not participate
in the violence and in fact there are
videos of ray epps saying let's not get
violent so
everything ted cruz is saying or or
tucker
some of it is just straight up lies and
some of it really doesn't mean much one
way or the other like let me give you an
example
um asha rangapa tweeted
the fact that there was one guy out of a
thousand people who were on an fbi
person of interest list and then was
taken off is not evidence that january 6
was an fbi led operation additionally
confidential informants and sources are
not feds are not fed so
even if ray epps was a confidential
informant for the fbi
that doesn't make him any more a fed
than when a drug dealer is a
confidential informant to the dea about
higher-ups that's not a dea agent that's
not a fed it's a drug dealer who's
agreed to cooperate with the fb with the
dea but none of that's even been
demonstrated but
ted cruz had to go and do tucker's
bidding ted cruz went and brought the
ray epps thing
to the senate hearing
take a look at this
i want to turn to the fbi
how many fbi agents
or confidence and i'm sorry i think
earlier i said this was a hearing on
covid this is a hearing on january 6th i
i think i missed but now i'm i think i
just misspoke earlier central informants
actively participated in the events of
january 6th
sir i'm sure you can appreciate that i
can't go into the specifics of sources
and methods uh did any fbi agents or
confidential informants actively
participate in the events of january 6.
now understand the way he's asking the
question
these are completely different questions
did fbi agents participate in the riots
did confidential informants participate
in the rights these are completely
different questions neither of which has
anything to do with reyes individually
sir i can't i can't answer that and ted
cruz knows that that can't be answered
in this format and it is such a vague
and broad question did any fbi agents or
confidential informants commit crimes of
violence on january 6th
6th
i can't answer that sir
did any fbi agents or fbi informants
actively encourage and incite crimes of
violence on january 6th 26th sorry i
can't answer that miss sadburn
who is ray epps
i'm aware of the individual sir uh
i don't have the specific background to
him well there are a lot of people who
are understandably very concerned about
mr f
on the night of january 5th
2021 epps wandered around the crowd that
had gathered
and there's video out there of him
channing tomorrow
we need to get into the capitol into the
capitol
this was strange behavior so strange
that the crowd began chanting he's got
fed fed
he's got charts on the floor of this uh
hearing room pictures of ray epps
fed fed
miss sandburn was ray epstein
yes sir i cannot answer that question
the next and of course the conspiracists
say well
if it can't be answered no then the
answer must be yes but anybody who
understands such a hearing would know
under no circumstances would someone
from the fbi or doj answer questions in
the way that ted cruz wants them
answered it is not evidence of anything
today
on january 6
mr epps is seen whispering to a person
and five seconds later five seconds
after he's whispering to a person that
same person begins to forcibly tear down
the barricades
did mr epps urge them to tear down the
barricades
sir
similar to the other answers i cannot
answer that
so they are absolutely loving this this
was a narrative pushed by right-wing
media
uh ted cruz loves it ted cruz is using
it to get back in the good graces of the
american right wing
after he had to go and grovel before
tucker carlson epps himself says he has
never been an informant for the fbi
he has never
been an informant for any law
enforcement agency and he is obviously
not an fbi agent he's a right-wing
anti-government group dude
and uh this is this they are absolutely
running with this one and and i will
show you how quickly they can signal
boost this